von nina liegt die bild zeitung ja auch
dieses thema bewegt sich heute auf der
titelseite ja aber dieses thema hat mich
sogar ehrlicherweise gefreut also ich
bin ja nicht immer nur die dauer importe
nena und zwar klimaschutz kostet
hunderttausende jobs da habe ich gedacht
als ich nicht den namen gelesen habe das
bild habe ich natürlich auch wieder ein
unternehmen hat er das fordert ist ja
wichtig einmal lese ich ig metall boss
hoffmann und erkennen sein foto ich so
was der klar also die es war ja früher
immer so sind hier die klassen feine die
unternehmer und die gewerkschaften und
die bequeme sich die gewerkschaften sind
für höhere löhne mehr ferien geringeres
renteneintrittsalter vermögenssteuer und
die unternehmer man kann also ein
bisschen billig erklären früher mit
thyssen die thyssens gegen die
gewerkschaft der kleine mann so und
jetzt plötzlich die grüne haben etwas
völlig überraschend es geschafft
gewerkschaften und unternehmer verbünden
sich anscheinend also die klassenfeinde
haben jetzt eine gemeinsame mission und
das sollte übrigens der klimapolitik
wirklich zu denken geben oder auch dem
was zum beispiel einer lena berger
vorschlägt sehr der gesagt verbote sind
innovationstreiber
in verzichte sind für mich keine
innovationstreiber aber das ja da haben
muss ich sagen da ist frau berger ob
wirklich ein großes stückelung dass die
klassenfeinde jetzt zusammen dafür
kämpfen dass man bei dem klimaschutz
mehr maß und mitte hat ein spannendes
die tat war auch der ig metall boss
hoffmann hat in dem interview gesagt
dass die politik die realität verloren
hätte und das ist ja auch was was die
unternehmer sagen mit blick auf den
klimaschutz also frau berbalk da ist
etwas besonderes gelungen die beiden
klassen vereine zu verbinden in einer
mission wie ich finde weil die
schlagzeile die jungunternehmer am
heutigen gipfel in berlin machen heute
morgen schon aktions demo genau das was
auch der gewerkschafter macht also
spannend spannende entwicklung
sagt wenn man es richtig macht dann
würde klimaschutz auch jobs schaffen
können genau das ist ja ganz ganz
wichtig beim klimaschutz also
selbstverständlich ist der klimawandel
eines der größten themen die wir haben
ich habe gestern noch zum freund gesagt
ich wünschte ich hätte
umweltwissenschaften studiert um noch
stärker argumentieren zu können
vielleicht hole ich das irgendwann mal
nach und da steht ja auch dieses bei
manchen politischen debatten habe ich
den eindruck dass die politik völlig den
kopf zur realität verloren hat und das
betrifft natürlich auch den klimawandel
weil und das steht auch in dem in dem
interview gut von ihm aufgeführte wir
brauchen ja erwischt können es ja
schaffen aber wir brauchen ja ein maß
der mitte das ist ein anderes zitat von
ihm da sieht man wieder die eigentliche
klassenfeind mit 45 jahren gearbeitet
hat soll schon mit 63 jahren in die
rente gehen können das war das thema was
ich eben meinte eigentlich hat man diese
sätze von ihm aber natürlich niemals
also eigentlich das sind nicht die sätze
die man erwartet und das ist eine
spannende entwicklung und wir müssen
beim klimaschutz maß und mitte finden
und abwägen und er hat da ja ganz der
darf spannende beispiele aufgebracht
auch die ausstiege zum beispiel auch
beim verbrenner motor auf lange sicht
selbstverständlich mit den ausstieg
erfolgen die frage ist wann und wie und
ich glaube das ist ganz ganz wichtig und
michaty mich hat es heute sehr gefreut
dass jetzt die gewerkschafter und die
unternehmer aktuell gemeinsam die
mission haben lasst uns ein klima wandel
schaffen aber mit maß und mitte
[Musik]